what are xenobots
so what's on about is uh self-assembling
little proto-organism it's also a
biological robot those things are not um
distinct it's a member of both classes
how much is a biology how much is it
robot
at this point most of it is biology
because what we're doing is we're
discovering natural uh behaviors of
these uh of these of the cells and also
of the cell collectives now one of the
really important parts of this was that
we're working together with Josh
bongard's group at University of Vermont
their computer scientists do Ai and
they've basically been able to use an
evolutionary a simulated Evolution
approach to ask how can we manipulate
these cells give them signals not rewire
their DNA so not Hardware but experience
as signals so can we remove some cells
can we add some cells can we poke them
in different ways to get them to do
other things so in the future there's
going to be you know we're now and this
is this is future on published work but
we're doing all sorts of interesting
ways to reprogram them to new behaviors
but before you can start to reprogram
these things you have to understand what
their innate capacities are okay so that
means
engineering programming you're
engineering them in in the future and in
some sense the the definition of a robot
is something you impart engineer yeah
and first versus evolve I mean um
it's such a fuzzy definition anyway in
some sense many of the organisms within
our body are kinds of robots yes yes and
I think robots is a weird line because
it's we tend to see robots as the other
I think there will be a time in the
future when there's going to be
something akin to the Civil Rights
movements for robots but we'll talk
about that later perhaps sure anyway
um
so how do you can we just Linger on it
how do you build a zenobot what are we
talking about here
from from whence does it start and how
does it become
the Glorious zenobot yeah so just to
take one step back one of the things
that a lot of people uh get stuck on is
they say well uh you know engineering
requires new uh DNA circuits or it
requires new nanomaterials you know what
the thing is we are now moving from Old
School engineering which use passive
materials right that things like you
know wood metal things like this that
basically the only thing you could
depend on is that they were going to
keep their shape that's it they don't do
anything else you it's on you as an
engineer to make them do everything
they're going to do and then there were
active materials and now computation
multiples this is a whole new era these
are agential materials this is your
you're now collaborating with your
substrate because your material has an
agenda these cells have you know
billions of years of evolution they have
goals they have preferences they're not
just going to sit where you put them
that's hilarious that you have to talk
your material and to keep your good
shape that's it that is exactly right
that is exactly right stay there it's
like getting a bunch of cats or
something and trying to organize the
shape out of them it's funny we're on
the same page here because in a paper
this is this is currently um just been
accepted in nature by engineering one of
the figures I have is building a tower
out of Legos versus dogs right yeah so
think about the difference right if you
build out of Legos you have full control
over where it's going to go but if
somebody knocks it over it's game over
with the dogs you cannot just come and
stack them they're not going to stay
that way but the good news is that if
you train them then somebody knocks it
over they'll get right back up so it's
all about so as an engineer what you
really want to know is what can they
depend on this thing to do right that's
really you know a lot of people have
definitions of robots as far as what
they're made of or how they got here you
know design versus evolve whatever I
don't think any of that is useful I
think I think as an engineer what you
want to know is how much can I depend on
this thing to do when I'm not around to
micromanage it what level of uh what
level of dependency can I can I give
this thing how much agency does it have
which then tells you what techniques do
you use so do you use micromanagement
like you put everything where it goes do
you train it do you give it signals do
you try to convince it to do things
right how much you know how intelligent
is your substrate and so now we're
moving into this into this area where
you're you're working with agential
materials that's a collaboration that's
not that's not old old style what's the
word you're using a gentle a gentle
what's that mean agency I think it comes
from the word agency so so basically the
material has agency meaning that it has
some some level of obviously not human
level but some level of uh preferences
goals memories ability to remember
things to compute into the future
meaning anticipate
um you know when you're working with
cells they have all of that to some to
various degrees is that empowering or
limiting having material as a mind of
its own literally I think it's both
right so it raises difficulties because
it means that it if you if you're using
the old mindset which is a linear
um kind of extrapolation of what's going
to happen you're going to be surprised
and shocked all the time because biology
uh does not do what we linearly expect
materials to do on the other hand it's
massively liberating and so in the
following way I've argued that advances
in regenerative medicine require us to
take advantage of this because what it
means is that you can get the material
to do things that you don't know how to
micromanage so just as a simple example
right if you if you you had a rat and uh
you wanted this rat to do a circus trick
put a ball in the little hoop you can do
it the micromanagement way which is try
to control every neuron and try to play
the thing like a puppet right and maybe
someday that'll be possible maybe or you
can train the rat and this is why
Humanity for thousands of years before
we knew any Neuroscience we had no idea
what's behind what's between the ears of
any animal we were able to train these
animals because once you recognize the
level of agency of a certain system you
can use appropriate techniques if you
know the currency of motivation reward
and Punishment you know how smart it is
you know what kinds of things it likes
to do you are searching a much more much
smoother much nicer problem space than
if you try to micromanage the thing and
then regenerative medicine when you're
trying to get let's say an arm to grow
back or an eye to repair so birth defect
or something do you really want to be
controlling tens of thousands of genes
at each point to try to micromanage it
or do you want to find the high level
modular control roles let's say build an
arm here you already know how to build
an arm you did it before do it again so
that's I I think it's it's both it's
both the difficult and it challenges us
to develop new ways of engineering and
it's it's hugely empowering okay so how
do you do I mean maybe sticking with the
metaphor of dogs and cats
I presume you have to figure out the
find the dogs and uh dispose of the cats
um because you know it's like the old
herding cats is an issue so you may be
able to train dogs
I suspect you will not be able to train
cats
or if you do you're never going to be
able to trust them so is there a way to
figure out which material is amenable
to hurting is it in the lab work or is
it in simulation right now it's largely
in the lab because we are our
simulations do not capture yet the most
uh interesting and Powerful things about
biology so the simulation does what what
we're pretty good at simulating are feed
forward emergent types of things right
so cellular automata if you have simple
rules and you sort of roll those forward
for every every agent or every cell in
the simulation then complex things
happen you know ant colony or algorithms
things like that we're we're good at
that and that's and that's fine the
difficulty with all of that is that it's
incredibly hard to reverse so this is a
really hard inverse problem right if you
look at a bunch of termites and they
make a you know a thing with a single
chimney and you say well I like it but
I'd like two chimneys how do you change
the rules of behavior for each termite
so they make two chimneys right or or if
you say here A bunch of cells that are
creating this kind of organism I I don't
think that's optimal I'd like to to
repair that birth defect how do you
control all the all the individual
low-level rules right all the protein
interactions and everything else rolling
it back from the anatomy that you want
to the low-level Hardware rules is in
general intractable it's a it's an
inverse problem that's generally not
soluble so
um right now it's mostly in the lab
because what we need to do is we need to
understand how biology uses top-down
controls so the idea is not not
bottom-up emergence but the idea of
um things like gold directed uh test
operate exit kinds of Loops where where
it's basically an error minimization
function over a new space it's not a
space of gene expression but for example
a space of anatomy so just as a simple
example if you have you have a
salamander it's got an arm you can you
can amputate that arm anywhere along the
length it will grow exactly what's
needed and then it stops that's the most
amazing thing about regeneration is that
it stops it knows when to stop when does
it stop it stops when a correct
salamander arm has been completed so
that tells you that's the right that's a
that's a uh a mean Zen's kind of
analysis where it has to know what the
correct limb is supposed to look like
right so it has a way to ascertain the
current shape it has a way to measure
that Delta from from what shape it's
supposed to be and then we'll keep
taking actions meaning Remodeling and
growing and everything else until that's
complete so once you know that and we've
taken advantage of this in the lab to do
some some really wild things with with
both planaria and frog embryos and so on
once you know that
um you can start playing with that uh
with that homeostatic cycle you can ask
for example well how does it remember
what the correct shape is and can we
mess with that memory can we give it a
false memory of what the shape should be
and let the cells build something else
or can we mess with the measurement
apparatus right so it gives you it gives
you those kinds of so so the idea is to
basically appropriate a lot of the um
approaches and Concepts from cognitive
neuroscience and Behavioral Science into
things that uh previously were taken to
be dumb materials and you know you get
yelled at in class if you if you for
being anthropomorphic if you said well
my cells want to do this and my cells
want to do that and I think I think
that's a that's a major mistake that
leaves a ton of capabilities on the
table